while 2018 is packed with a number of
highly anticipated big-budget games it's
also filled with a bunch of exciting new
indie games that you shouldn't miss out
on either there are so many hidden gems
to keep track of but here are five indie
titles that we've played and we can't
wait to see more of even if you aren't
familiar with the name Keita Takahashi
there's a good chance you've played his
most famous creation Katamari Damacy
that game solidified his reputation as a
developer with an eye for cute
characters and observed scenarios and
well tomm Takahashi's upcoming ps4 and
PC game fits the bill perfectly it's a
game about experimentation and discovery
where the act of play is valued over
completing explicit challenges some
could argue that it's not a game at all
so be it maybe what Tom deserves to fall
into a category all its own because it's
definitely unlike anything else around
playing as a mayor with a bomb under his
hat it's your job to create colorful
explosions to attract new citizens and
you've accomplished this by holding
hands with different objects and
characters in your environment the pre
explosion interactions produce many
kinds of unexpected surprises lending
with Tom a consistent charm that only
grows with each explosion has new
potential friends and sources of
entertainment enter the scene we've only
played a fraction of what Tom so far but
it instantly puts a smile on your face
and we can't wait to see what else
Takahashi has up his sleeve
[Music]
speaking of Katamari Damacy donut county
is a lot like that just in Reverse in
donut county you control a hole in the
ground that grows the more you can get
to fall inside of it start small with
lawn chairs and pebbles and work your
way up to buildings and even mountains
all while solving physics based puzzles
to fit everything in the whole donut
county is a solo project by indie
developer Ben Esposito who worked on
what remains of Edith Finch and the
unfinished Swan playing as a whole
sounds really silly and donut County's
colorful art and sassy animal characters
are cheekily charming but in practice
it's meditative and relaxing to play
we're excited to see more of what donut
county and its trash or treasures have
to offer and hopefully what's at the
bottom of that hole
[Music]
the gardens between uses some clever
tricks to present a story about
nostalgia and friendship between two
protagonists as a narrative focus puzzle
game each stage is presented as a
hodgepodge of memories referencing
moments and locations from their youth
maneuvering both characters past giant
constructs are the past you'll come to
understand that their memories hold the
deeper meaning one that examines their
bond and how it ultimately shapes their
future playing with time and perspective
move your character's forward and
backwards will affect time to solve the
many puzzles you'll often have to
separate the two characters and have
them tackle their own unique challenges
to help the other move forward but by
the end of every stage though unite and
move on to the next level
together the gardens between is
definitely one you'll want to keep an
eye out for in the future
[Music]
Celeste is a magical game that will
challenge you in a multitude of ways
it's platforming is really really hard
and you'll likely get frustrated at
you're fumbling fingers for failing a
jump or at your slow brain for not
figuring out how to get to the next safe
zone but when you get to that checkpoint
it's satisfying to know that your
fingers and brain are not in fact
useless more than platforming though
Celeste story is challenging the main
protagonist Madeline is faced with the
horrible journey both climbing a
mountain and battling her own mind and
at times it's not easy to watch her
suffer the game's writing is such that
it's easy to project that suffering onto
yourself and that can really make it
tough to face playing the next level but
you should absolutely do so it's a story
with an ending worth the struggle and
the cast of character is so endearing
you'll be rooting for them to succeed
just expect to fail a few leaps of faith
along the way waive the pacifist offers
a unique twist to the side scrolling
beat him up genre instead of relying on
standard button mashing to beat up
pixelated goons the game focuses on
timing based mechanics were you Parry
and dodge enemy attacks to defeat them
the result plays like a bizarre
lovechild between Streets of Rage and
Street Fighter 3 the action is fairly
straightforward enemies take turns
trying to fight you gradually teaching
you the varying pace of their attacks
before eventually tiring out and at
which point you simply push them over
while this fighting style sounds
counterintuitive for a beat em up it
works surprisingly well
the act of parrying and evading is easy
to execute it it offers a steady degree
of challenge especially against multiple
foes with different attack patterns add
that on top of a fist of the north star
like narrative and you have an action
game that's as charming as it is
mechanically distinct so those are the
five biggest indie games that we're
looking forward to this year but again
with so many to choose from
there are plenty that we didn't mention
if you know a game that people might be
sleeping on put in the comments below
and don't forget to visit GameSpot comm
for more coverage on all of these games
and more